[Music]
[Music]
I think that he will probably be further
ahead in this exercise than I am when it
comes to questions about myself I'm
interested to see what she does cuz
she's a pretty humble person take a step
forward
if you trust hey leads do your laundry
take a step forward if you wouldn't
change anything on Hayley's face step
forward if you wish Hayley could see how
beautiful she was take a step forward if
Isabel gives good advice take a step
forward if you think Isabelle has a
beautiful body
take a step forward if you wish Isabelle
can see how beautiful she was take a
step forward if Vicki makes you love
[Music]
take a step forward if you think Vicky
lights up the room take a step forward
if you believe in Vicky take a step
forward if Cesar gives good advice take
a step back if you wish Cesar was
capable of achieving his goals take a
step forward if you believe in Caesar
[Music]
you
[Music]
it should be okay I should just be able
to like walk forward if that's how I
like truly feel but there's like a
moment of hesitation and then I just
like don't move I think it's sort of
like symptomatic of being in a loving
relationship where you need that other
person to support
what are you doing back there I'm real
you know see Assad I thought I'd be more
confident but it's just I guess I the
honesty just came out I guess I was
being honest with myself thank you for
believing me
Oh Chrissie
it's fair right I don't know I think it
falls in line with what I said earlier
about how just I'm really hard on myself
all the time and I know that to me like
she's perfect in my eyes you know and
there's like little things here and
there where you're like does she make
silly decisions where it's like I don't
necessarily see that as a negative
[Music]